hi everybody welcome to Street cocoa I
lay down the ground like a rising zombie
coming out of the ground there you know
it's Halloween I'm wearing a black shirt
because I forgot to wear another shirt
and sorry we're kind of off kilter today
everybody and I'll tell you why because
we're getting ready for something very
special
it's the Conan and Friends tour that's
right hashtag Conan Fred's exactly and
you can go to Team koco.com slash tour
and get your tickets now if they're
still available I think there's still it
there's I'm still available some of ya
are just it's worth the cost it's yeah I
could see why one would not want to
invest I would pay $800 to not talk to
Conan for a day and I hope you're
watching and you know why all right uh
yes we're gonna be we're gonna be going
to Washington DC New Jersey Detroit
Michigan oh yeah hometown Boston oh my
god New York Atlanta Houston Austin
Nashville Chicago Minneapolis Milwaukee
Los Angeles Los Angeles Seattle Denver
Vancouver and San Francisco that's right
that's right we're gonna be joined by a
bunch of great people Ron Funches
James Beach a bunch of people have been
on our show Taylor Tomlinson Lori Kyle
Martin of course Moses storm and the
hilarious Flula Borg we all know and
love Rory Scovel is gonna be there
marina Franklin all these amazing people
yeah but they'll also be some special
guests showing up along the way and of
course we'll be following along on tour
as well so if you can't if you're not in
one of those cities or can't make one of
those dates or don't want to pay $9,000
for a Conan package then you can follow
along for everything will be doing on
the web so follow all of our you know
follow Team Coco on Instagram and make
sure you subscribe to our Facebook page
which hopefully you are because many of
you might be watching as well as YouTube
and of course at Conan O'Brien on
Twitter and it's gonna be a crazy fiesta
Beth would you say I think crazy cross
country tour Fiesta I don't know why I
did that
I just felt like I needed to do
something you know LeBron's in LA now he
does the chalk thing that's a big deal
all right we're gonna be playing Grim
Fandango remastered today Grim Fandango
one of my favorite games have you ever
heard of it back it's amazing and super
fun by LucasArts lumber Zack said the
NYC guns were gone as soon as I heard
about it yes exactly no San Diego sorry
rose but you could also drive up to LA
and see us
I agree Grim Fandango is one of the best
adventure games ever made and we're
gonna start playing it right now so
here's the deal
it takes place in a world do you want me
to tell you about it you just want to
watch the cutscenes oh okay
that's smart she wants that's code for
zippy oh this is perfect now this is
Mimi that's see ya now this is made back
in the day back it's four three four by
three Grim Fandango
I love he's intimidating yet everyone
here is a skull call your lawyers
LucasArts I'll turn the subtitles on a
second hey O'Malley could you uncover
that below he's got terrible credit soon
Rogers making a lot of skull jokes bleh
break a leg
there we go I will be careful why does
he sound like Puss in Boots you're just
gonna have a Banderas asks then so all
we can afford is a walking stick we
can't afford a car a train or a boat
the boss told me to tell you not to
leave early tonight
wants to talk to you about something
when he gets back from his trip don't
worry
this looks like very like this windows -
really what does metier although you
gotta say like yeah Detroit the design
is called see lucky was wearing lifts
[Music]
we're a private detective
[Music]
Oh perfect alright now I can walk around
let me let me quickly put voice oh yeah
all right here we go all right so we're
Manny we're a private detective and
we're in this world of the Day of the
Dead
I will said it does feel a bit
remastered the movement
you gotta put us in the top right am i
got it mass poisoning oh my god magic
that was your boss's voice you had to
listen to that all day
I know Beth what do you are you big
Halloween fan what are you dressing up
as for Halloween was great what did you
end up doing last year nothing I think
it was like a Tuesday Jesus all right
we're a New York know where we I think
for a couple years I've been what does
everybody dressing up as for Halloween
do you guys all have your costumes ready
travel agent oh we're travel agents
sorry sorry but we become a private eye
don't we
my man I've I be all right let's get out
of here
oh oh no the game is not automatically
saved at the are we just gonna go
through this and not save we should that
sounds like Conan to me I know what that
means I can't read hack your comment oh
that's just what it says sounds like
Conan to me what the guy oh the guy
screaming sounds like coating coating is
not a screamer he's more of like a
menacing whisper wouldn't you say you
don't have to be when kind of screaming
it's funny when he's menacingly
whispering it's sexy okay okay okay I
get it
I do like a sarcastic secretary here we
go I really know where we should go
maybe we'll go here let's go down you
guys have a bone to pick
oh my god you guys these puns are
amazing wait what am I going here this
way this way looks cool oh this is oh
that's a mirror all right
hello happy Lux from Luxembourg I just
interesting Blake snowflake
Alex a joker sorry you had a sad night
last night what happened the girl I have
a crush on it doesn't like me so is that
helping anybody's feelings where am I
going here okay Jesus
maybe I should yeah maybe I should look
at the stuff I have here what is this
examine our special work order okay
[Music]
around the edges there is some I got
fewer suits alright my scythe I like to
keep it next to where my heart used to
be you and me both vali I like to keep
it next to where my heart used to be
Jesus alright there anything else is
that all we have we have to work order
we have the car do the site that's it
alright we gotta figure out where to go
here I gotta go to the mall well let's
see let's go this way
yep alright we're going outside ah here
we are it's a world it's the world of
the Dead the land of the dead
yeah that blend of the Dead has great
architecture I love this music oh my god
we got a pen yeah no this is fun we got
a little fare over here let's see what's
up if we break it open our giant pieces
of candy gonna fall out and crush the
skeletons ha ha ha
focuses I remember spending two hours
downloading the 30 megabyte demo can I
knock a lot of pigeons around here
oh you can run oh good oh here we go
[Laughter]
you'll make no bread of the Dead I love
it guys do I go as grim fandago way down
in Haiti stab the dead not mall oh the
mail I need to go to the mail it's right
here keep do here so I need to go back
and do the get the mail just grab a worm
isn't the land of the dead Arizona how
old in this game this case shady fridge
what's up it's been a minute
this game is 98 i feel like practicing
would cheese
[Music]
my god he doesn't my god it's the rudest
mind but they aren't mine supposed to
shut up what should I say here twist me
up one of them a fella will play Friday
the 13th is free on PS Plus you should
be able to find plenty of chat players
next time who will play that next week
poets what's a great poet Whitman Oh
Robert Frost this is great oh wow
whoa alright alright so we need that we
need some bread right balloon and some
bread has anybody played this game
before all right we got some bread ma'am
how big is my jacket now how do I get
over there can I can I walk y'all played
we happy few I feel like this game is a
stepping stone same sort of mechanics
that interesting
that's for the worm okay Ariel says ask
for the worm ah I get it I get it we
just keep asking for worms till he
doesn't have anymore balloons and we put
him out of business all right we got it
now what do we do anybody I got the dead
worm a rebuilding it's like enough it's
a 90s jack and they're still deflating
all right
[Music]
I don't think I can get dead worm
alright did it now what yeah we just
stole some bread all right I'm going
back I'm gonna run around a bit more as
for the worm again mm-hmm what's Bad Fur
Day Michael Bryant all right I'm gonna
ask for the warm again she's bang hey
India what's up balloons this whole
stream is gonna be asked why why do we
need the worms maybe he'll get sick of
us maybe he'll get sick of us some
lettuce oh I got to put this in my thing
how many three or four okay if you keep
playing will tell you fair enough see
important it over I don't know if chats
screwing with us or not is is this all
just gonna be you guys making me get
dead worms ah Fisk all right
how are you supposed to figure out what
to do here
how many dead where's getting yet you
need to go to the poisoning Oh to try to
get your car you need a balloon cat and
two dead worms what is this game all
right we got okay we got a couple dead
worms and now I'm gonna get a balloon
cat a cat the worm guys really getting
under my skin
yes waffle turrets about done I might
dress up as Fandango for Halloween
that's kind of a good outfit it's a suit
with a thing would people get it though
all right we got the cat we got the
worms all right here we go now we got to
get to our car which i think is back
this way yeah yeah Moochie Chan oh is
this the way to go it's a very dark
scary alley no stop doing the thing with
the jacket oh heck yeah I can climb up
this
[Music]
whoa this is cool should I think about
this way oh my god this looks dangerous
[Music]
can I jump oh don't do the thing don't
stop doing it maybe that's why I need
the worms for it oh that's just how I
get back into my office apparently
[Music]
you know what I should save my Gabe I'm
just learning yeah we autosave has
ruined us as a society slot-1 whoa fun
fact good luck buying a soundtrack to
this game CD copies run about $200
that's crazy I just need a couple empty
blues that get back to the office back
in the elevator oh yeah don't know
people are saying don't climb up this
I'm gonna crawl back down why is it here
then what's your you know I'm gonna get
back in there would it matter if he
jumped he'd still be dead I mean that's
a good point we're getting into grim
fandago is getting ass into some
existential questions here all right
back to the office
got a couple balloons we're ready to go
this game is bananas Barsky I haven't
done anything yet
it's Jordan's office oh that wasn't my
office okay
the Rope is for later got it all right
you guys are being very helpful don't
worry about it
[Music]
what do I have to do here I read all
this stuff there's nothing to do in my
office yeah look at that weird your
socials file
out whoops oh you can't lose the
game-saving just helps me happen to
crash this is actually a doughnut County
underground music rights are insane fair
enough all right go to the lower floor
all right
[Music]
have I visited my workmate not the
secretary no I have not his files all
right that's probably okay sorry
what about what's what's in this door
whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm in the garage
they do yeah the computer looks another
father thing I haven't met Gladys either
is this the right way to go all right
let's check let's check it out here we
go
what do we got here
which so Beth if you're dressed up as
Columbo then every time you leave a room
you have to come back and say it's gonna
be a long night exactly talk to
secretary yeah none of us have to worry
about diet in this game it's pretty
great yes
[Music]
what poisoning despacho poisoning I'm
sorry okay I can't find my driver yes
yes oh I see so when somebody dies they
show up in our to me enough about me
let's learn a little bit about our
secretary you know here we go
visca we're gonna need some help here
Thank You Alexander we're all great
nerds so Gladys is the best check the
tool box in the garage we read that
Gabriel we can see everything all right
you guys gonna play black ops core maybe
if we can get out of this land of the
dead all right well let's okay gotta go
hit the bricks all right so I think we
go down to the garage right go down we
got to get for this poisoning guys
we gotta give this poisoning everybody
the deck of cards what the Brendan
balloons from the vendor you'll need
them later think you have a long night
all right we got to go find our driver
here is this the way
nope oh wait here we go this is a
big-ass garage alright maybe he's in
here
[Music]
we know it's when the Japan episodes
airing it know we have it we don't know
yet oh my god
Seba service we know but we we like a
good challenge hey dizzy death Galante's
oh this is glottis I hope it's glottis
come on Gladys hello Justin do you think
it takes him to brush it all those teeth
are you a driver how are we gonna get a
car that's gonna fit you know the other
elevator upstairs to get to the lobby to
go outside to get the vendors an alley
next to the building we did we got the
we got the balloons and the cap the
capital in and the bread already so far
come on Gladys shady fridge this game is
great oh you're not too big you're just
right Gladys don't listen to the haters
bodice you know what you're not too big
the cars are just too small
exactly we need like a giant monster
truck oh here we go yeah Gladys
and 899 Sami a Slayer Darth gotta go to
the boss alright my god what do you
think he eats Jesus alright gotta go get
this work order signed
I think this what this a religion wasn't
ms-dos game I'm drinking Lacroix Tony
times three all right let's talk to her
he's not in his office it's [ __ ] I
gotta give this poisoning dude what are
you yelling at me about the poisoning
how long was she away from her long it
takes to link a paperclip a while now
maybe we go was that the boss's office
that we were in before we go outside and
climb up the thing cuz it wasn't our
office now do we climb up ah see now we
got Avalon Knights hooking us up we
don't care we don't care all right let's
see Marie climbed up that rope that's
getting into the boss's office I think
here we go remember these games guys
back in the day quick quick jaunt into
the alley here there we go up the old
Roper ooh
pretty strong by the way for not having
any muscles
that's how I got these guns paperclips
guys these are all paper that's all
paper games no it's all paper good here
we go nice you know game I played a lot
where in the world is Carmen Sandiego
you think they've rebooted that already
oh there we go
all right see he's not in here
it's all a sham well we are salute time
to read to him it ah no don't go out the
thing this is by the way how most of my
childhood was spent we had a like a like
a a weird hallway in our house that no
one ever used so I just put my computer
in it and I spent most of my life in
that weird like side hallway playing
this game and where in the world is
Carmen Sandiego ah see here we go see
it's the computer perfect
all right back out the window basically
these games aren't awesome but it's just
a matter of like going around the room
until you find a little birds look like
seagulls they're all it's just a matter
of like going around the room and
hitting the button till it does
something cuz there's not like a ton of
options hey Bobby bear what's up it's
kind of like this game it's like the
opposite of like an open-world game but
it's also like not on Rails because it's
just open-world enough to make it
annoying alright we changed the bosses
auto-response now we're gonna get this
work order signed so Gladys could be our
limousine driver by the way these games
do do a great job at capturing it how
annoying life is the minutiae and how
you have to do everything 19 times so at
first console my very first console was
an odyssey
I'm extremely old by the way
here we go and they changed the angle so
you know it's gonna be great
really secretaries have all the power
anyway in this world she's kind of like
reminds me of uh what annie potts from
ghostbusters well I don't you don't have
lungs I don't understand oh there we go
oh here we go whoo nice jump cut to the
Flint he's gonna fix the car up we've
got our work duds on
this is great this is great also sam and
max hit the road I think was like a big
one of these games I had the Odyssey at
the Commodore 64 when I was a kid I'm so
old by the way that Robin Hood so
there's this game Robin Hood and the way
you loaded it on the computer was white
tape it was a concet and so you had a
cassette player hooked up to the
computer and it would have to play the
entire tape for like an hour to load one
game and then when you got killed you
have to load it again there's always a
guy with the flaming arrows you know I
should do is try to find an emulator for
that game because I need to go back and
beat that game like to satisfy me this
is great I love this no lungs so no
threat of lung cancer that's true sammy
very smart oh my god look at this what
is happening oh is this the land of the
living
this is insane wait are we like them
what is happening this game is awesome
oh wait I have to get my scythe or
whatever
yeah cut him open this is dope it is
true like why does the Grim Reaper have
a safe anyway like you know it's funny
that he can use it to actually do
something uh well baby soul this is so
weird
Hey
this is great the jigglers like what the
hell nation download Rob's have you
don't own the game
I do technically owned Robin Hood back
at my house in Michigan so I do okay
okay alright alright just go do your
thing do you think this is the most oh
my god sinner eyes you that's the best
pun so far this is the most humorous
death of all who's Evan says Adam do you
play fortnight my name is Erin I don't
play for tonight very well but I played
it yes what are these tapes you speak Oh
says above middle C sale Tony three
times says he's got I think that's a
toupee because I don't think skeletons
can grow hair ooh
I'll feed it I'll be the same Monty the
c64 I I don't know that I played that
game yeah gum him up gum him up we don't
need to hear from this guy anymore
Hayes and Eve this is a classic kavorka
it's hot it's it's October man it's the
month of Halloween is the season of long
shadows it's my favorite time of year I
missed like LA it's all blue skies and
Sun and people people in good shape it
sucks out here the rest of the world and
America have it great because you get to
experience fall and autumn it's awesome
the transition
transition seasons are the best all
right so what am i doing go back to my
desk here oh actually you know what I
should ask the secretary he missed a
great thought of any food puns for
Assassin's Creed Odyssey for your
cooking stream yet no I haven't although
my friend guys came up with instead of
Luigi's Mansion Linguini's mansion
pretty great also there's another one Oh
instead of life is strange too leaf is
strange I don't know what about shadow
of the Tomb Raider shadow nuts of the
Tomb Raider no I got to figure out I I'm
now accepting food puns for my next
episode of dinner in a video game
Assassin's Creed could be Assassin's I
don't know I'm not good at puns that's
the problem oh the store is open Oh
somebody's working out I'm mad don't
don't leave I guess I should talk to him
I've got this weird am I gonna talk to
or what we're just gonna hate you don't
leave don't my god Katamari Damacy
calamari Damacy that's brilliance I
actually downloaded Katamari Damacy
dizzy death that'll be the next one
calamari Damacy is pretty great
call the foodies good oh that's good I
got me writing these down a salad screed
we can do better
totally made sense I think older
videogames put more effort into the
writing whereas present games focused
too much how the game looks writing is
the second I agree
Assasin's grapeseed is okay Assassin's
weed is pretty good but I can't make
weed that's the problem you got to make
something Assassin's feed oh yeah yeah
Siraj yes hey Conan is upstairs
preparing for today's show oh I'm gonna
drink this guy's booze just goes right
out my pants assassin's seed what is
that though rocket leaf is okay tea
checks I don't know what that means but
I'm into it
oh he's got it just gonna keep drinking
Assassin's cream of mushroom soup I mean
it's funny that's ins cream is pretty
good
I don't wait till Friday and play the
new Mario Party we'll play that next
week chia seed pudding all right that
could work let's close his record baby
how do I do that how do I close his
record
I'm already
we'd salad assassins peed because they
pee I don't know what I'm talking about
Cesare they odyssey looks cool she a
throwback to my very first episode you
assassins kada see I don't think I want
to give myself food poisoning again
thank you is this how I close the file
when I close the file here assassin's
beef doesn't that's not a pun Gbagbo
tort Knight tort Knights actually pretty
great tort night is awesome actually I
love that because desserts are hard I
haven't done a lot of desserts tour
tonight's great maybe I do tour tonight
you came up with that red bread
redemption of course broken gamer I'm
just waiting for it to come out go
downstairs and back in the room where he
foamed up Bruno there's stuff to do
there thanks bisque
assassins Mead that's a good idea
I can make beer assassins meat is great
well I do have to remember some of these
what was the one torte Knights great
maybe that'll be this week
it's just the room where I foamed him up
is that over here somewhere
I want my dead worms is this it's just
the right way this isn't the right way
it's locked where is that room again
I need a map yeah this game is total
nostalgia too you can jam the hydraulic
mail oh that's interesting with what
Kristen oh the bread maybe I put the
bread in there by the exit outside okay
great
use the dead worm balloons to the vendor
to get the chemicals from the coffin
room okay got it
I can't somehow go this way but I see it
instead of saying how come I can I've
turned around oh I see this is just a
bad angle definitely putting the bread
in there I'm using the normal controls
crash beetroot we can do better use the
dead worms use those in the tubes breads
for later you fill the balloons Oh with
gas and jam them in there ah thank you
guys alright here we go
[Music]
nope nope nope nope nope no yes how
would you ever figure out this is what
you're supposed to do if you didn't have
somebody helping you there's no way so
is this gonna cost like an explosion or
something
that guy does not skip leg days his
[ __ ] hate a mark lews gamers plan for
this year yes it's like somebody stuck a
suit on a thing that's always upstairs
the old trapdoor get one of the other go
to alright one from each of those got it
alright back upstairs we go I want
something to happen before the stream
ends there we go you guys are just
joining us Conan is going on tour
starting November 2nd in Washington DC
go to cotton koco.com slash tour uh and
what is it called again it's Conan and
Friends Team Coco presents Conan and
Friends a night of stand-up comedy and
an evening of stand-up comedy and
investment tips now you read what it
really is Team Coco presents Connor and
friends there you go go to yoga calm
there are no invest although maybe you
never know but probably not but go to
team koco.com slash tour and we're going
all over the place don't make me read
all these all these dates again don't
make me read up forever go with our
friends Ron Funches Larry kill Martin
Moses storm Flula Borg will be there of
course our favorite James Beach Taylor
Tomlinson who am I forgetting Who am I
forgetting
Who am I forgetting marina Franklin and
I said Flula but we'll say him twice
because he's so fun Flula Borg Flula
Borg
if you saved three times it's like
beetlejuice he'll show up like a like
and a portal venous schnitzel open up
and then he'll step out of beer I'll
spell on the floor he's a very German
fella but yes we're very excited come
see us come on a lot of those dates are
sold out but some of them are not sold
out and of course if you can't make the
shows or can't get a ticket we will be
covering everything on Team Coco and all
of our amazing social channels for you
guys I'm going to select this and put it
in here
right
[Music]
I'm such a dick why am I such a dick no
way this goes well let's do it again
nope
yep Conan in French who's your fair
friends well I have no friends except
for back but I don't think Beth we could
send her Mia friend probably M co-worker
oh here we go we did it no more work
yeah we're real able I don't know blue
is hilarious fine alive 2016 you can all
you can follow everything on Team
koco.com and of course on our to go go
Instagram Conan O'Brien Twitter Team
Coco Facebook and YouTube as well we'll
be putting up a ton of stuff all over
the place alright what's next the bread
now what do we do Fisk help us out one
more to go oh no oh I needed a third one
damn it I didn't know any of three warms
downstairs we go this is my whole life
my entire childhood was spent running
around in games like this there's a game
called Leisure Suit Larry that was like
a sexy game and you had to go around and
like you know for a kid you're like ooh
like trying to figure out but then you
know when you do with a lady it just
says censored those is a box so up and
down I was like oh this is so crazy
like it's amazing I had a pretty racy
childhood it's pretty crazy
yep that's how that works all right we
got one more goddamn bullet here we go
let's do it when do we get to see you
play the most difficult game of her life
in real life streaming when Cala B I
don't know maybe I'll try to do more
life streaming it's pretty smile life is
pretty sad as Beth can attest you I
think it's pretty sad Leisure Suit Larry
man there you go
ghosts and goblins ghosts goblins is
really hard Gosei goblins is [ __ ]
because as soon as you beat it you have
to play it again it's like oh that was
just fake like your princess is in
another castle kind of [ __ ] that's
the biggest lie of my childhood your
princess you get you beat you a beat
Bowser and your princess is in another
castle it's [ __ ] all right let her
rip
[Music]
the princess is always in another castle
all right here we go oh it worked
oh yeah they tried to age gate the game
with a history quiz at the beginning
that's true that was really funny Scott
Adams text adventures on cassette tapes
what was that one Gorn or something or
door nor Zorn maybe it was Oren as a
text-based adventure
[Music]
shadowgate the princess is alive in the
pot the pie is or the cake is a lie all
right here we go so this is going back
in here now what do I do
Zorin yet King's Quest games were awful
that's true okay let's get out of here
but I don't understand why we did that
what was the point if the server's down
what's the point
oh this part is done talk to the rival
okay you know champ hey champ
we're gonna talk to him or what you
still walk around yo hey yo dude yo yo
yo yo
hi hey you know what forget it I'm going
over here ain't dumb what's your
screensaver password oh damn get away
from my computer Manny LucasArts had
some great games
want the cone bro bring the show to
Washington DC we're going to Washington
DC on tour are we not I think Oh the
actual show oh that's a Wing Commander
very hard sook guys very focus I'm
punching his bag I agree this compass
out man we're almost done I just want to
do one thing in this game try to get his
mail from the server room
oh god this is never gonna happen
where's the dumb server room now where's
this where's the server room oh all
right bye oh my goodness good lord
do we think we go down this elevator
yeah I say we go we haven't really just
feel like it all right let's go this way
oh wait this is a very confusing angle I
wish they didn't do it like this but
they did very confusing angle grim
fandago
is this the server room this is like not
the server room yeah this is like an
embalming room oh this is the coffin
room oh I'm not seem that competitive
it's across from the copy room I mean
the coffin room this is the coffin room
right
oh is this this is outside Oh Oh weird I
don't even know that was a door alright
let's try to find some oh here we go
did some a-hole throw a bunch of
expanding foam in here thank you final
life that's very nice the first MMO was
a LucasArts game to him lock the door
that's opens when the guy closes it
still open oh I see I see oh so I should
lock it
[Music]
scratches but there
[Applause]
what is happening we know how to blow
this up now so I just keep talking to
him till I get I'm trying to just choose
the right thing before we have to end oh
my god all right oh I see I need to just
leave all right and then when he locks
the door oh my god
so when he leaves I'll go back in there
ah there we go there we go perfect thank
you guys for your help this guy would be
good at twerking I agree he won't leave
before you do all right perfect
I love people who aren't good at their
job here we go
all right did you do let's go back in
whoa there we go
open that door baby now he's just like
damnit
damn it it's locked you guys oh damn it
what do we have in here that we can use
fill the dead the dead worms I'm done
with the dead I don't have any more dead
worms can I jump up I need to get that
thing I think right what do I have that
I can use here this I have a card what
does it say use a hole punch I don't
have a hole punch card alright Jesus
Christ how what no why would I hold
punch a deck of cards for no reason
doesn't make any sense this game this is
again this is why I didn't talk to
anyone when I was a child says spending
my life the hole punching cards no no no
no can I oh here's the hole punch right
here pull out our cards something you
would never do ever for any reason if
this game is literally let's just try
[ __ ] until it works right here we go
whole bunch okay great we did it all
right back downstairs oh my god
good luck with my adventures thank you
jungle Germania it makes all the sense
seance in the world all right we'll
accept it we'll accept it gotta go
across this way here we go into this
room all right now we've hole-punch our
card all right so like you do so to
reiterate here's what we've done we've
gotten balloons and bread from a vendor
[Music]
yeah we did it
Oh see we're gonna get a great package
here that's got hot we've completed the
prelude of
Grim Fandango we did it Oh glottis my
man or my thing oh my God look at this
amazing hell the hell ride we've got our
dragula yeah take that whatever are ya
this is fantastic I'm also wearing lifts
just full you know disclosure I'm not
this tall all right guys we're gonna end
there thank you guys for helping us out
this is awesome
Grim Fandango what a fun game I think
it's taking us back it's taking us all
back
thank you for vist can you guys for the
help that was awesome hello J Dilla
lento please again we are going on tour
starting November 2nd go to to koco.com
slash tour and for our to our called
Team Coco presents Conan and Friends and
evening of stand-up and investment tips
yes we did it
just rolls off the tongue and I passed
that by mistake so to make sure to go to
comm / tour for that make sure you're
following all of our social channels and
it's Halloween season guys we'll see you
right back here next Wednesday for
another great Halloween theme stream go
go see you guys later
[Music]
you